>> Jesse: THE LEFT MUST BE
SICK AND TIRED OF ALL THIS
WINNING.
AFTER STRIKING OUT ON RUSSIAN
COLLUSION AND ACCUSING THE
PRESIDENT OF BEING RACIST, SOME
OF THE MEDIA ARE TRYING TO
TOPPLE TRUMP BY LITERALLY
CHEERING FOR A RECESSION.
WATCH THIS.
>> I HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR ABOUT
TWO YEARS THAT I HOPE WE HAVE A
RECESSION.
>> A RECESSION WILL BE VERY
WORTH GETTING RID OF
DONALD TRUMP OF THESE POLICIES.
>> SEEING THAT WE HAVE BEEN AN
ECONOMIC EXPANSION FOR THE
BETTER PART OF TEN YEARS, IT'S
ABOUT TIME WE GET A RECESSION SO
THAT WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS
THIS IS THE BEST ECONOMY EVER,
IT'S NOT.
IF WE DID FACE RECESSION, IT
WOULD BE NORMAL AND IT WOULD BE
OKAY.
>> Jesse: TRUMP HITTING BACK.
>> I THINK THE WORD RECESSION IS
A WORD THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE
BECAUSE IT'S JUST A WORD THAT
CERTAIN PEOPLE, I'M GOING TO BE
KIND, CERTAIN PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA ARE TRYING TO BUILD UP
BECAUSE THEY WOULD LOVE TO SEE A
RECESSION.
WE ARE VERY FAR FROM A
>> Jesse: KATIE, THE LAST TWO
QUARTERS WE'VE HAD GROWTH, NO
HIGH GAS PRICES, NO BUBBLES IN
REAL ESTATE OR ATTACK.
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, STRONG WAGES.
WITHOUT SAYING YIELD CURVE, TELL
ME WHERE YOU THINK THIS IS
COMING FROM.
>> Katie: I ONLY TOOK A FEW
BUSINESS CLASSES ARE NOT GOING
TO THROW THE YIELD CURVE BALL
YOU.
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE
RECESSION HURTS OTHERS IN PEOPLE
WHO THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS TO
STAND UP FOR THEY ARE STRUGGLING
IN A LOT OF WAYS BECAUSE TRUMP
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE AWAY A LOT OF THE
ARGUMENTS DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
MAKING ON THE ECONOMY FOR YEARS.
WAGE INCREASES WERE STAGNANT
UNDER OBAMA AND FOR A COUPLE
YEARS BEFORE THAT.
THEY HAVE GONE UP.
THE MIDDLE CLASS ISN'T
BOLSTERED.
THE TAX CODE DID AFFECT
MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILIES.
THEY ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
GOING INTO AN ELECTION, RACISM
BEING THROWN OF THE WALL IS NOT
WORKING.
THE ECONOMY IS SOMETHING PEOPLE
CAN GAUGE NO MATTER WHO IS IN
OFFICE AND SAY ARE THEY WORKING
TO MAKE MY LIFE BETTER?
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT
ELIZABETH WARREN IS TRYING TO
MAKE AND IT'S THE ARGUMENT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
MAKE BUT FOR PEOPLE TO SAY THAT
WE NEED RECESSION TO GET TRUMP
OUT, IT'S DISGUSTING BECAUSE IT
ACTUALLY HURTS PEOPLE.
WELFARE, IT HURTS THEIR
FAMILIES.
IT MAKES LIVING REALLY
DIFFICULT.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES.
HAVING A RECESSION IS LIKE
SAYING THERE'S GOING TO BE
ANOTHER SUNSET TOMORROW.
OF COURSE.
WE WILL BUT HOPING FOR A FOR
POLITICAL GAIN IS PRETTY GROSS.
>> Jesse: THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY DOESN'T BELIEVE IT
BECAUSE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS
THAT AN ALL-TIME HIGH IN RETAIL
SALES AND SPENDING AMONG
CONSUMERS, TWO-THIRDS OF THE
ECONOMY, VERY HIGH RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S A BIG DISCONNECT.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK THERE'S
A DISCONNECT AT ALL.
WALL STREET IS NOT THE MEDIA.
RIGHT NOW I'VE HAD A
ROLLER COASTER MARKET FOR THE
LAST MONTH OR SO, ESPECIALLY THE
LAST WEEK OR SO.
IT'S EVIDENCE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN THE MONEY MAKING BUSINESS WHO
THINK WE ARE ON SHAKY GROUND IN
TERMS OF OUR ECONOMIC FUTURE.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT THIS WAS
OBAMA'S ECONOMY.
>> Juan: IT HAS BEEN IN TERMS
OF GETTING US OUT -- GO
>> Jesse: BUT NOW THAT IT'S
GOING DOWN, IT IS TRUMP'S
ECONOMY.
>> Juan: TRUMP HAS TRIED VERY
HARD IN TERMS OF SAYING I CUT
REGULATIONS, CUT TAXES FOR THE
RICH.
MOST OF THAT TAX CUT --
>> Katie: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
DID A FACT-CHECK ON THAT.
>> Juan: 25% OF THE CART WENT
TO THE 1%.
HERE'S THE OTHER TELL.
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING AFTER THE
FED.
JEROME POWELL.
HE SAYS IT'S THE FED IS THE
BIGGER THREAT TO OUR ECONOMY
THAN CHINA.
HE SAYS WE NEED MORE TAX CUTS.
I THINK HE SAYS LET'S THINK
ABOUT CUTTING THE PAYROLL TAX.
HE SEES THAT THERE IS TROUBLE
COMING.
HE WOULDN'T BE SAYING THESE
THINGS IF HE WASN'T WORRIED.
THE ANXIETY TELLS YOU IT'S NOT
THE MEDIA, IT'S WALL STREET AND
THIS IS TRUMP.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THE
PRESIDENT SEEMS WORRIED AT ALL.
I THINK HE WANTS TO JUICE AN
ALREADY HOT ECONOMY.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK THE
MEDIA IS AS POWERFUL WITH
BUSINESS OR SOME ARMY GET OUT TO
BE.
BUSINESSES WATCH THE MARKETS.
THERE ARE THINGS CONCERNING
OVERSEAS, NOT NECESSARILY IN OUR
COUNTRY BUT LIKE GERMANY FOR
EXAMPLE.
OBVIOUSLY THE TRADE WARS A
LITTLE BIT OF A CONCERN.
ONLY FUNDAMENTALS CAN CAUSE A
RECESSION.
THE MEDIA CAN'T CAUSE A
RECESSION BUT I AGREE THAT
CHEERING ON A RECESSION IS NOT A
GOOD LOOK FOR ANYBODY.
THE REPUBLICANS NEED MORE FOR
MESSAGING FOR JUST THAT THE
MEDIA WANTS A RECESSION.
I THINK THAT'S THE PRESIDENT
TALKING ABOUT TAX CUTS, IT GOES
RIGHT BACK TO WHERE THE
REPUBLICANS ARE VERY STRONG AND
EVEN IF NANCY PELOSI WILL NEVER
ALLOW A VOTE FOR TAX CUTS, FOR
ME POLITICALLY THAT'S WHY
REPUBLICANS SHOULD TALK ABOUT
ALL THE MORE.
THE PRESIDENT, THE WEEK BEFORE
THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS IN 2018 AT
A RALLY SAID WE HAVE A BIG
MIDDLE-CLASS TAX CUT COMING AND
HE PROMISED IT.
NOBODY EVER TALKED ABOUT IT
AGAIN AND NOW THEY ARE STARTING
TO TALK ABOUT IT AND I THINK
THEY ARE SEEING WHAT TOOLS DO WE
HAVE COME AT A PAYROLL TAX CUT
DOESN'T HELP THE RICH.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY WORKING
TOUGH JOBS, TWO OR THREE JOBS,
THEY ARE THE MOST BANG THE --
PAYING THE MOST PAYROLL TAXES.
>> Greg: FOR THE MEDIA, THE
RECESSION IS LIKE BEETLEJUICE.
YOU SAY IT ENOUGH TIMES, MAY BE
THE MONSTER WILL APPEAR.
I KIND OF DISAGREE WITH YOU,
DANA.
I KNOW.
NO, NO, NO.
YOU AND I BOTH READ A VERY
IMPORTANT BOOK CALLED
"INFLUENCE."
WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF THE
STRUCTURES IN OUR COUNTRY ARE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY INFLUENCED.
THE MEDIA PSYCHOLOGICALLY
INFLUENCES A LOT OF THINGS.
OUR MARKETS ARE AFFECTED BY
OPTIMISM AND FEAR.
TRUMP HAS BENEFITED BY AN
OPTIMISTIC POPULATION.
PEOPLE ARE EXCITED AND THEY WANT
TO INVEST.
IF YOU CAN MESS WITH OPTIMISM,
YOU CAN MESS WITH THE MARKETS.
IF YOU CAN INSTILL FEAR, INSTILL
THE IDEA --
THE POLICE, THEY CREATED THIS
IDEA THAT ALL POLICE CREATED
BRUTALITY WHEREVER THEY WENT.
THEY ARE DOING IT WITH RACE.
EVERYONE IS A RACIST.
THEY CAN INFLUENCE OUR CULTURE.
I THINK THEY CAN INFLUENCE THE
ECONOMY AND I THINK IT'S
SELFISH.
THEY ARE DOING IT BECAUSE THEY
HATE THIS GUY.
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA, USAMA
BIN LADEN WAS KILLED.
THAT WAS A VERY PROUD MOMENT.
I DIDN'T SAY DAMN IT, I WISH
THEY HADN'T GOTTEN HIM BECAUSE I
CAN'T STAND OBAMA.
IT'S KIND OF THE SAME THING.
I WANT A BAD ECONOMY BECAUSE I
HATE THIS GUY.